hello and welcome to my video series of
mall bio explained in three minutes
where i explain the concept of molecular
biology in less than three minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel
hit that subscribe button today we are
going to talk about
gateway cloning technology which is a
site-specific recombination based
cloning system
and this is based on how phage
integrates its dna
in the e coli chromosome so this
reaction
has two steps step one also known as bb
clonaze reaction and step two also known
as electronics reaction
and these steps are very similar to the
way
a e coli a phage integrates its dna
and excise its dna from the e coli
genome
so it's kind of like a in vitro version
of this phenomena
now let's get back to conventional
cloning system where we use
plasmid then we restriction digest that
plasmid
to integrate our gene of interest with a
ligation reaction
but many a times this reaction fails
and we always scratch our head to
understand what has gone wrong
so is there a better way to do it of
course yes
using lr and bp clone as reaction things
can
be simpler and more efficient
so in order to understand gateway
cloning we need to understand
how a phage virus integrates its dna
inside e coli so after infection the
phage dna
integrates into the e coli chromosome
with the help of a site directed
recombination
phage dna has attp sites whereas
the ecoli chromosome has att
b sites and they can recombine with each
other
and that is how phage dna integrates
with
the e coli genome while excising
out similar kind of site specific
reaction
is used by the
phage virus now scientists thought
whether they can use this kind of
strategy in a cloning method
and of course that's the birth point of
gateway cloning the first reaction is
known as bp clones reaction where we add
bp colonies
and in this particular reaction we have
our gene of interest
flanked by particular recombination site
then we have our donor vector then we
have our bp clone is enzyme
when we add all of these together
the gene of interest which is flanked by
att
b sites gets integrated
into the donor vector with the help of
side directed
recombination then we perform the error
clone step
where we add error clone is
destination vector and the donor vector
now the gene of interest is going to be
transformed from the donor vector into
the destination vector
so here is our donor vector with gene of
interest flanked by
att l sites and here is our destination
vector
with attr sites again
these two sites can perform
site-directed recombination
and that is how the destination vector
would get
the gene of interest pretty simple
and less time consuming lastly
these destination vector has to be
integrated inside
competent e coli cells to get
recombinant colonies
and this step is very simple and
conventional
transformation reaction has to be
performed where competent cells would be
combined
with these plasmids
and ultimately incubated on eyes
for kind of like 15 minutes then
followed by a heat shock
we would incubate it in an eyes again
and then
plate this on a petri plate
so after inoculation and incubation
overnight we should be seeing some
recombinant colonies
and that's it we should have our gene of
interest inside these recombinant
colonies which we can check
by colony pcr so now you learn
how gateway cloning work the advantages
of gateway cloning are the following
it maintains the written frame
directionality is
maintained no restriction no ligation
only recombination the restriction the
reaction takes place
within an hour and the efficiency is
more than 90 percent
so as per our tagline we can say cloning
becomes as easier as breathing
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to check
out all my playlist in this channel
and if you like my videos please share
it with your friends
you can also follow me in instagram or
facebook thanks for listening thank you